SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLEY DODD. DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LEMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO SATO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS THAT WE CAN RETURN TO
OUR DESKS. WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED. SENATORS AND GUESTS
BEYOND THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE LED IN PRAYER
BY SENATOR LAIRD. AFTER WHICH,
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. DENISE
LEVERTOV OF INBEGINNERS IN
CANDLES OF BABYLON IN 1982. SHE
SAID, WE HAVE ONLY BEGUN TO KNOW
THE POWER THAT IS IN US. IF WE
WOULD JOIN OUR SOLITUDES IN THE
COMMUNION OF STRUGGLE. SO MUCH
IS UNFOLDING THAT MUST COMPLETE
ITS GESTURE. GOD OF INFINITE
CREATIVITY, THE CELEBRATION OF
PRIDE MONTH ACKNOWLEDGES AND
APPRECIATES THE RESILIENCE OF
THE MANY LGBTQ PLUS PERSONS WHO
HAVE OVERCOME EONS OF STIGMA,
DIMINISHMENT, AND
MISUNDERSTANDING WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME MAKING INCALCULABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE ADVANCEMENT
OF SOCIETY. AS WE CELEBRATE THE
FULFILLMENT OF OUR HIGHEST
IDEALS OF LOVE, APPRECIATION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE MYSTERY OF
OUR HUMANITY, MAY WE EXPRESS
MORE CLEARLY OUR INTENTION OF
INCLUSIVITY AND RADICAL
HOSPITALITY FOR THOSE STILL
MARGINALIZED. TOGETHER, WE HAVE
THE POWER TO ELIMINATE ALL FORMS
OF INJUSTICE, OPPRESSION, AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. AS WE PROCLAIM WITH
PRIDE THAT DIVERSITY IS NOT A
PROBLEM TO BE SOLVED, BUT A
MYSTERY TO BE LIVED. AND LET US
SAY WITH CYNDI LAUPER, I SEE
YOUR TRUE COLORS SHINING
THROUGH. DON'T BE AFRAID TO LET
THEM SHOW. YOUR COLORS ARE
BEAUTIFUL LIKE A RAINBOW. AMEN,
AMEN, AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
JESUS. HAPPY PRIDE. STATE SENATE
. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SENATE RULE 55 IS SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW GUESTS ON THE FLOOR TO
WELCOME FORMER SENATOR LARA IN
THE BACK. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR MAY 28TH,
2024 THROUGH MAY 30TH, 2024 WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. I APOLOGIZE IF I'M
SCREAMING. I AM COMPETING WITH
CONSTRUCTION.
WE'RE ZOOMING THROUGH. WE ARE
UNDER CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. UNDER SECOND READING FILE,
WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 491 WITH AMENDMENTS 2449,
WITH AMENDMENTS. SECOND READING
WILL BE CONSIDERED. READ UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. SENATOR
LAIRD, ARE YOU PREPARED? HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
DISREGARD. SENATOR LAIRD, YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. FINAL ITEM
NUMBER THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF TAMIKA MOSS FOR APPOINTMENT
AS SECRETARY OF THE BUSINESS,
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY. PRIOR TO THIS ROLE, SHE
WAS FOUNDER AND CEO OF ALL HOME
AND SERVED TO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE. APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY EIGHTH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
WIENER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED, I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF TAMIKA MOSS'S
NOMINATION. I HAVE KNOWN TAMIKA
FOR A VERY LONG TIME, WORKING
WITH HER ON VARIOUS HOUSING
ISSUES AND ISSUES AROUND
HOMELESSNESS. SHE'S A STRONG
LEADER, VISIONARY PERSON AND SHE
IS ALREADY IS AND WILL BE
EXTRAORDINARY IN THIS ROLE. I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
BLAKESLEY, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
TODAY'S APPOINTMENT, GIVEN THE
STATE'S EVER RISING HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION. MISS TAMIKA MOSS HAS
A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING MUCH NEEDED CHANGE. I'M
PARTICULARLY ENERGIZED BY THIS
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE MISS MOSS'S
RECORD DEMONSTRATES HER ABILITY
TO HANDLE COMPLEX CHALLENGES AND
CREATE REAL PROGRESS ON
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
BAY AREA. IN HER PREVIOUS ROLE
AT ALL HOME. WHILE I SUPPORT HER
100% AND I ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME, I
MUST COMMENT ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS ROLE. OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE FED UP THAT HOMELESSNESS
CONTINUES TO GROW ACROSS THE
STATE. OVER THE PAST DECADE, WE
HAVE SEEN THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
DECLINE INTO A SEEMINGLY ENDLESS
CYCLE OF HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS. THIS IS MADE WORSE
BY THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SHELTER
ALL THOSE WHO ARE LACKING
HOUSING. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
OUR STATE'S 181,000 UNHOUSED
HOUSED CITIZENS LACK SHELTER AND
WE ARE FAILING ACROSS THE BOARD
TO GET THEM INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING. OUR EFFORTS TO PREVENT
AN INCREASE EXITS FROM
HOMELESSNESS ARE NOT KEEPING
PACE WITH THE RATE AT WHICH
PEOPLE ARE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS. INSTEAD, OUR
UNHOUSED NEIGHBORS FIGHT TO
SURVIVE IN THE ELEMENTS,
OCCUPYING PUBLIC SPACES,
INCLUDING RIVER BEDS AND TRAIN
TRACKS, PARKS AND SIDEWALKS. THE
SHEER VOLUME OF HUMAN BEINGS
OCCUPYING OUR PUBLIC SPACES IS
OVERWHELMING FOR THE REST OF US,
AND IS OUTRIGHT DANGEROUS FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE UNSHELTERED,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS, THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE ATTACKED THIS
PROBLEM BY INVESTING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND
REQUIRING GREATER COORDINATION
AMONG STATE, FEDERAL, LOCAL AND
NONPROFIT AGENCIES. HOWEVER,
CALIFORNIANS ARE FRUSTRATED THAT
DESPITE ALL OF THESE EFFORTS,
THE RECENT AUDIT SHOWS WE CANNOT
DEFINITIVELY POINT AT WHAT MANY
OF OUR EFFORTS ARE ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING. MISS MOSS DID NOT
CREATE THIS SYSTEM, AND ALL THE
PROBLEMS THAT COME WITH IT. BUT
SHE IS INHERITING RESPONSIBILITY
OVER IT. SHE HAS HER WORK CUT
OUT FOR HER AND THE ROAD AHEAD
WILL NOT BE EASY. MOVING THE
NEEDLE WILL REQUIRE INTENSE
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
AMONG ALL STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED,
INCLUDING US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THEREFORE, I ASK
THAT MISS MOSS WORK WITH ME AND
THIS ENTIRE BODY TO ENSURE WE
HAVE TRANSPARENCY WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR STATE'S PROGRAMS. THEIR
COSTS, AND PARTICULARLY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THEIR OUTCOMES. TO
START, WE NEED COMPLETE DATA ON
PROGRAMS. WE, AS THE
LEGISLATURE, MUST BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
WORKING, THAT WE ARE GETTING
VALUE OUT OF WHAT WE ARE
SPENDING. THE FAILURE TO DO THIS
UNDERMINES PUBLIC CONFIDENCE. I
ALSO ASK THAT MISS MOSS WORK
WITH ME TO FIGHT HARD FOR WHAT
MAY BE HARD. WE KNOW GENERALLY
WHAT PROGRAMS WORK, WHAT
PROGRAMS DON'T WORK, AND WHAT IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT INTERIM
AND PERMANENT SHELTERS EXIST. WE
MUST ENSURE EVERY CITY DOES ITS
PART AND THAT WE MOVE PEOPLE OFF
OUR STREETS AND INTO SHELTERS
WITH MORE FERVOR AND URGENCY
THAN EVER. I KNOW THAT OUR
INCOMING BKSH SECRETARY CAN RISE
TO THE CHALLENGE AND FIND A WAY.
WITH THAT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH TOMIKA MOSS AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. SENATOR, DO WE HAVE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
? SENATOR LAIRD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. I THINK THEY MAKE
THE CASE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO
JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. OCHOA. BORG PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. I RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMMER. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. DALY.
GROVE HURTADO. JONES NGUYEN.
OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA. CIERTO.
WILK. AYES 30. NØ. ZERO.
APPOINTMENTS CONFIRMED. MEMBERS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL TAKE
UP THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTION. OUT
OF ORDER TODAY. FILE ITEM 20 SR
96. AFTER ADOPTION OF THE
RESOLUTION, WE WILL RETURN TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR TO
INTRODUCE THE LGBTQ PLUS CAUCUS
PRIDE HONOREES. SENATOR EGGMAN
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 96 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. RELATIVE TO
LESBIAN, GAY, BISEXUAL,
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER PLUS PRIDE
MONTH. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS TO CELEBRATE GAY PRIDE
MONTH. HAPPY PRIDE EVERYBODY,
I'VE REALIZED MY STAFF DIDN'T
PROVIDE ME TALKING POINTS, BUT
THAT'S NEVER STOPPED ME BEFORE,
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY, THIS IS
MY LAST YEAR IN OFFICE, AND, AS
A RETIRING MEMBER TO BE ABLE
THIS YEAR, I JUST THINK TO FEEL
SO MUCH COMMUNITY WITH ALL OF MY
PEERS AS THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN UNDER ATTACK, THE SUPPORT
THAT WE GET FROM OUR ALLIES AND
OUR ALLY CAUCUS MEMBERS, OUR
FRIENDS ACROSS THE AISLE,
EVERYBODY WHO CAN AGREE THAT
LOVE AND ACCEPTANCE AND
INCLUSION IS THE WAY TO GO
FORWARD. IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
THEY'RE REDOING THE CAPITOL. OUR
VOICES CONTINUE TO RING TRUE AND
STRONG BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF NOISE OUT
THERE, AND A LOT OF THAT NOISE
TRIES TO DROWN OUT THE VOICES.
SO WE USE EVERY OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE TO POINT OUT THE NOISE FOR
WHAT IT ACTUALLY IS, IS
BACKGROUND NOISE TRYING TO DROWN
OUT THE VOICES FOR EQUALITY AND
FOR EQUITY AND FOR LOVE. AND SO
IT IS MY PRIDE TO BE HERE AND TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS CAUCUS.
THAT IS NOW REACHED, THE FIRST
CAUCUS IN A NATION TO REACH 10%
OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY, WE HOPE
TO CONTINUE TO GROW THAT, AND AS
, REPRESENTING THE L IN THE
LGBTQ ARC, I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT
A THRILL IT WAS TO RIDE ON THE
BACK OF DIKES AND BIKES ACROSS
THE BRIDGE AND Ã UP CAPITAL
MALL, ON THE BACK OF THAT BIG
OLD VICTORIA THAT YOU COULD
FEEL. AND IT JUST FELT PEOPLE
ALL UP AND DOWN THE STREETS WERE
JUST COMING OUT AND LOOKING AND
WAVING, AND THEY WE MADE AS MUCH
NOISE, AS WE POSSIBLY COULD.
VERY SMALL DELEGATION, BUT A
WHOLE LOT OF HEART AND A WHOLE
LOT OF PRIDE, AND I'M SO PROUD
OF THIS CAUCUS, AND I'M SO PROUD
OF THIS BODY. I'M SO PROUD OF
THIS BODY THAT CONTINUES TO SHOW
UP FOR PEOPLE. THE STAFF WHO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT US OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. THE
SERGEANTS THAT WHEN WE PRESENT
BILLS THAT ARE SOMEWHAT
DIFFICULT AND PEOPLE COME IN AND
SAY THE MOST VILE THINGS YOU
EVER WANT TO HEAR, ATTACKING OUR
COMMUNITY, ATTACKING OUR VALUES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO SIT THERE NO
MATTER WHO THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE, THAT THE ANGER OF THOSE
THAT WOULD ATTACK US DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE, THE, THE, THE, THE
FALLOUT OF THEIR WORDS OR THEIR
IMPACT FOR THEIR WORDS TO
ANYBODY BUT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
OWN VERY SMALL AUDIENCE. SO
LET'S CONTINUE TO MAKE THAT
AUDIENCE SMALL AS WE CONTINUE TO
RAISE OUR VOICES WITH LOVE AND
RESPECT FOR EVERYBODY. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON SR 96. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATORS MANUEL CUEVAS,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, AND GOOD
AFTERNOON, MEMBERS. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF SR 96 THAT RECOGNIZES
THE MONTH OF JUNE AS LGBTQ PLUS
PRIDE MONTH. PRIDE MONTH
COMMEMORATES THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITIES RESILIENCE AND THEIR
FIGHT TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY FREE
FROM HATE AND DISCRIMINATION, A
STRUGGLE THAT BLACK AMERICANS SO
PROFOUNDLY UNDERSTAND. AS BLACK
PEOPLE HAVE HISTORICALLY FOUGHT
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT TO DEFEND THE
RIGHTS OF ALL AND INCLUDING AND
PARTICULARLY SO, THE LGBTQ PLUS
CITIZENS, BLACKS, TRANSGENDER
ACTIVISTS LIKE MARSHA P JOHNSON
AND MISS MAJOR GRIFFIN-GRACY,
BOTH CENTRAL FIGURES OF THE
STONEWALL UPRISING IN JUNE OF
1969, HAVE HELPED TO PAVE THE
WAY FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL
OF US TO BE PRESERVED AND
UPLIFTED, AND PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE IN OUR LGBTQ. PLUS
COMMUNITY. I ALSO WANT TO LIFT
UP BLACK CULTURAL CHAMPIONS LIKE
RUPAUL AND OTHERS WHO PRESENT
THE BEST OF ARTISTRY IN
ENTERTAINMENT AND ACTIVISM
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WELCOMES EVERYONE TO THE TABLE
TO PARTICIPATE, RATE, TO LEARN,
TO GROW AND TO CELEBRATE. WHILE
GREAT STRIDES HAVE BEEN MADE
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES,
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO DO
TO PROTECT THE HUMAN RIGHTS OF
THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY. K¾T.
IN RECENT YEARS, AS MY GOOD
SENATOR TALKED ABOUT FROM
STOCKTON, WE HAVE SEEN THE
RESURGENCE OF POLICIES THAT ONCE
AGAIN AIM TO PUSH MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES BACK INTO THE
SHADOWS, TO SILENCE THEIR VOICES
AND TO LIMIT THEIR RIGHTS, WHICH
IN FACT LIMITS THE RIGHTS OF
ALL. IN 2023, THERE WERE OVER
520 ANTI-LGBTQ+ BILLS INTRODUCED
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AND WHEN I REMEMBER
OUR MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
DOCTOR CORI JACKSON, FROM OUR
CAUCUS INTRODUCED AB 1078 LAST
YEAR TO PREVENT SCHOOLS FROM
BANNING BOOKS ON RACE, GENDER
AND SEXUALITY. IT MET MUCH OF
AND CONTINUES IN MANY
COMMITTEES. THIS YEAR TO DRAW
OUT THE MOST VIOLENT REACTIONS
AND THE MOST VILE TESTIMONY THAT
HARMS NOT JUST THOSE IN THE
ROOM, BUT PARTICULARLY OUR YOUNG
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT, LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. IT IS A DISHONOR TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE
HOUSE, IT IS A DEMONSTRATION OF
HOW OUR COLLEAGUES CAN ALSO BE
TARGETS OF HATEFUL ATTACKS,
SIMPLY BY TRYING TO ENSURE
RIGHTS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AS
WE'VE ALL SEEN, SOME OF OUR,
SOME OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
AND ATTACKS ON OUR GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO, AND IT PAINS
US ALL, AND WE ARE ALWAYS
HOLDING UP THIS COMMUNITY IN OUR
PRAYERS FOR PROTECTION AND FOR
SAFETY AS WE BATTLE AGAINST
HATRED THAT IS GROWING MORE
FIERCE EVERY DAY. AND ACCORDING
TO A STUDY BY THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN PROGRESS, LGBTQ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER RATES OF
DISCRIMINATION AND VIRTUALLY
EVERY SOCIETAL SETTING,
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE,
EMPLOYMENT, HOUSING AND PUBLIC
SPACES. I THANK OUR CAUCUS FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FORWARD AND FOR YOUR
COURAGEOUS WORK TO EDUCATE AND
UPLIFT US ALL, AND I LOOK
FORWARD FOR AN I VOTE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION. SENATOR
BECKER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SR
96. IN FACT, I JUST HOSTED A AT
1230 ONLINE TOWN HALL ABOUT THE
50 YEAR STRUGGLE FOR LGBTQ
EQUALITY IN SILICON VALLEY,
FEATURING OUR OWN COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR LAIRD. A PRIDE MONTH IS
A TIME FOR CELEBRATION OF
IDENTITY AND COMMUNITY. THE TERM
PRIDE EXISTS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SHAME THAT HAS BEEN FOISTED
UPON THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY BY
THOSE WHO WOULD WISH TO SEE THEM
ERASED. IN HIS TIME, HARVEY MILK
MADE CRYSTAL CLEAR THE PARALLELS
BETWEEN JEWISH HISTORY AND THE
MOVEMENT IN THE UNITED STATES TO
EXCLUDE LGBTQ INDIVIDUALS. THE
ANTI LGBTQ MOVEMENT WANTS TO
FORCE QUEER PEOPLE BACK IN THE
CLOSET THROUGH LIES AND
VIOLENCE, IF NECESSARY. THEY
WANT TO ERADICATE DRAG QUEENS
AND TRANS PEOPLE FROM PUBLIC
LIFE. THE EVENT, NEW SLURS, BUT
THEIR GOALS ARE THE SAME AS THEY
WERE IN THE TIME OF HARVEY MILK,
AND IT IS OUR DUTY TO RESPOND,
AS HE DID TO SHOW THROUGH OUR
ACTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA IS A
BEACON OF HOPE FOR THE
MARGINALIZED AND A SAFE HARBOR
FOR THE OPPRESSED, AND A MODEL
OF THE INCLUSION AND RESPECT
THAT ALL PEOPLE DESERVE. THAT'S
THE NOISE THAT SENATOR EGGMAN
WAS TALKING ABOUT. WE GOT TO
DROWN IT OUT. THE WHOLE COST
STARTED WITH BARRING JEWISH JEWS
FROM PUBLIC LIFE, PAINTING US AS
A THREAT TO CHILDREN, ISOLATING
US FROM THE BROADER COMMUNITY,
BURNING BOOKS, PREVENTING
NON-JEWS FROM LEARNING ABOUT US
AND GENERALLY EXCLUDING US FROM
SOCIETY. AMONG THE OLDEST AND
MOST EFFECTIVE TROPES FOR
JUSTIFYING THE HARMS COMMITTED
AGAINST THE JEWISH PEOPLE HAS
BEEN ACCUSATIONS OF CHILD
MUTILATION. TODAY WE SEE THIS
LIBEL LEVIED AGAINST THE LGBT
COMMUNITY IN FULL FORCE. SO AS
WE TALK OF PRIDE, I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LGBTQ MEMBERS OF
OUR JEWISH COMMUNITY WHO HAVE
EXISTED ACROSS HISTORY, THOSE
WHOSE DUAL IDENTITIES INFORM AND
ENRICH ONE ANOTHER, AND THE
IMMENSE PRIDE AND LOVE WE FEEL
AS A COMMUNITY FOR THEM. THIS
PRIDE MONTH, AMIDST ALL THAT
DARKNESS AND CONSUMING OTHER
STATES AND ONLINE, I'M PROUD TO
JOIN YOU AS A BODY THAT WORKS
TIRELESSLY TO EMBRACE, LOVE AND
STAND UP FOR WHAT IS RIGHT. I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
UNFORTUNATELY, I CAN'T TELL THEM
TO TAKE THE NOISE OFF THE FLOOR.
SO WE'LL CONTINUE WITH SENATOR
MINH, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I
WANT TO STAND AND EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION AS
WELL, THIS IS A MONTH THAT HAS
BEEN, AS HAS BEEN ELOQUENTLY
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUES, IS
ABOUT PRIDE. IT'S ABOUT
DESTIGMATIZATION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, IN THE ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES, BEING LGBTQ STILL
IS A SUBJECT OF A LOT OF STIGMA.
WE MAKE UP 6.2% OF THE US
POPULATION, BUT ONLY 3.8% OF THE
LGBTQ POPULATION. AND THAT'S NOT
BECAUSE WE HAVE FEWER LGBTQ
MEMBERS. IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT
STIGMA OF PEOPLE NOT WANTING TO
SELF REPORT. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
WE LIVE AT A TIME RIGHT NOW WHEN
ANTI-LGBTQ HATE IS ON THE RISE,
WHEN PEOPLE ARE ACTIVELY TRYING
TO CREATE LARGER STIGMAS, TO TRY
TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE, SCARED TO FEEL
HATE. AND THIS IS COMING, OF
COURSE, ON THE HEELS OF THE
ANTI-ASIAN HATE EPIDEMIC THAT WE
SAW. AND I THINK THIS PARTICULAR
PRIDE MONTH IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER, THAT WE ALL STAND
HERE AND EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT AS LOCAL LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, FOR PRIDE, I
REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT RIGHT
NOW ARE TAKING, GETTING RID OF
AND BANNING THE PRIDE FLAG.
WE'VE SEEN THIS IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH AND THE COUNTY OF ORANGE,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE SYMBOLS
MATTER. AND SO I WANT TO STAND
HERE TO SAY THAT WE STAND WITH
THESE PEOPLE. TO ALL MY
CONSTITUENTS, I WANT TO SAY THAT
WE SEE YOU, WE ACCEPT YOU. WE
LOVE YOU. THIS IS A TIME OF
PRIDE. THIS IS A TIME OF
CELEBRATION. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
PROGRESS, NOT REGRESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
LAIRD, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY BY SPEAKING TO
THE JOY OF WHAT PRIDE IS AND
WHAT PRIDE MEANS. AND YES, THE
FIRST PRIDE I MARCHED IN SANTA
CRUZ IN THE LATE 70S, A FEW
YEARS BEFORE MY HONOREE, THE
MAYOR OF MONTEREY, WHO IS HERE
TODAY, WAS BORN, WE HAD WE HAD
MORE PROTESTERS THAN WE HAD
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING. WE NEEDED
POLICE PROTECTION. AND I HAVE
TOLD YOU THE STORY OF A FEW
YEARS AGO WHEN I LINED UP IN A
CAR TO GO IN THE PARADE AND TWO
FLOATS IN FRONT OF ME IS THE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA FLOAT, AND
THEY HAVE A TEN FOOT JOINT AND
IT'S SHOOTING OUT SMOKE. AND WHO
WAS ASSIGNED TO WALK NEXT TO
THEM? BUT THE SHERIFF AND HIS
TOP DEPUTIES. AND SO THEY WALKED
BACK TO ME AND SAID, WOULD YOU
MIND IF WE WALKED WITH YOU? AND
THERE IS THE ARC OF HISTORY FROM
NEEDING THEIR PROTECTION DECADES
AGO, TO ME BEING THE SAFE PORT
IN THE STORM. AND YESTERDAY IN
THE 49TH ANNUAL PRIDE IN SANTA
CRUZ, WE HAD 7000 PEOPLE AND IT
WAS THAT JOY THAT YOU USUALLY
SEE, THE, THE LIBRARY EMPLOYEES
HAD THEIR SPECIAL BOOK CART
DRILL TEAM, CHEER SAN FRANCISCO
WAS THERE THROWING PEOPLE IN THE
AIR. THERE WAS EVERYBODY FROM
EVERY WALK OF LIFE, EVERY COLOR,
EVERY ORIENTATION. THE IMMEDIATE
PAST PUBLIC WORKS DIRECTOR OF
WATSONVILLE WENT BY IN A TUTU ON
ROLLER SKATES, AND THE SANTA
CRUZ HIGH MARCHING BAND BROUGHT
IT UP. AND SO WHILE WE HAVE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WERE MENTIONED,
WE ALSO HAVE THE JOY OF OUR
PROGRESS, AND WE HAVE THE JOY OF
WHO WE ARE. AND THAT IS WHAT
PRIDE WEEK IS ABOUT. AND THAT'S
WHY WE SHOULD SUPPORT SR 96.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, YOU RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MADAM
PRESIDENT, SO ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, IT'S
MY HONOR TO RISE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR 96 RELATIVE TO THE
LGBTQ PRIDE MONTH DURING PRIDE
MONTH, WE RECOGNIZE THE
RESILIENCE AND THE DETERMINATION
THÀNH IN SPITE OF THE NOISE,
WE'RE VOICES WILL BE HEARD. THE
RESILIENCE AND DETERMINATION OF
MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE FOUGHT
AND CONTINUE FIGHTING TO SIMPLY
LIVE THEIR LIVES FREELY AND
AUTHENTICALLY. Kò LGBTQ, LATINO
SHOWS HAVE BEEN MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE UNITED
STATES IN EVERYTHING FROM ARTS
TO MILITARY POLITICS. JOSEPH
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND MOVEMENTS
FROM THE FAMOUS MEXICAN PAINTER
FRIDA KAHLO AND JOSE JULIO
SIERRA. THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
CANDIDATE TO RUN FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE IN THE U.S. SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. IN
1961, THE LGBTQ LATINOS HAVE HAD
A SIGNIFICANT INFLUENCE ON US
CULTURE THIS PRIDE MONTH, AS WE
RECOGNIZE THE MANY CONTRIBUTIONS
OF THE LGBTQ PLUS INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS OUR NATION, THE LATINO
CAUCUS REAFFIRMS OUR COMMITMENT
TO FIGHT AGAINST ALL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND INJUSTICE.
ALTHOUGH HISTORIC SUPREME COURT
RULINGS STRUCK DOWN, REGRESSIVE
LAWS AFFIRM THAT THE RIGHT TO
MARRIAGE EQUALLY AND SECURE
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS FOR LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS, THERE ARE EFFORTS
TO ROLL BACK THESE HARD FOUGHT
VICTORIES. IN SPITE OF THE
VICTORIES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN
FAR TOO MANY STATES, LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS STILL LACK
PROTECTIONS FOR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS AND DIGNITY IN HOSPITALS,
SCHOOLS, PUBLIC ACCOMMODATIONS,
AND OTHER SPACES. WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO WITNESS THE TRAGIC
SPIKE IN VIOLENCE AGAINST
TRANSGENDER WOMEN OF COLOR, LGBT
C¯ YOUTH WHO ARE AT
DISPROPORTIONATE RISK OF
SELF-HARM. SO AS WE CELEBRATE
LGBTQ PRIDE MONTH, WE MUST ALL
BE DILIGENT AND STEADFAST IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO HELP END VIOLENCE
AND DISCRIMINATION AGAINST THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
FOR A JUST AND EQUITABLE AMERICA
FOR ALL. WITH THAT, I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR, THE
LEGISLATIVE LGBTQ CAUCUS, FOR
OUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING SR 96. OUR VOICES
WERE LOUD ENOUGH. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A BRIEF PAUSE FROM THE
NOISE TO CONTINUE OUR CEREMONY.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, I RISE AS
THE CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SR
96 AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BEGINNING OF PRIDE MONTH, AS OUR
AUTHOR NOTED, THIS YEAR WE
REACHED 10% LGBTQ REPRESENTATION
IN OUR LEGISLATURE. SO THE FIRST
BODY, I THINK, ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO DO SO. AND IN THAT
SAME YEAR, 2023, WHAT I SAID
SAME SESSION YEAR. SO YOU KNOW,
WE'RE IN A TWO YEAR SESSION. WE
ALSO PASSED OUT ACA FIVE TO
REPEAL THE PROPOSITION PROP
EIGHT, WHICH OF COURSE MADE IT
ILLEGAL TO BE MARRIED. NOW SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT WONDER, WHY DID WE
NEED TO REPEAL THAT WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT GAVE THAT RIGHT?
BUT AS WE KNOW, SUPREME COURTS
CHANGE. SO WE HAD TO GET IT OFF
OUR BOOKS. AND, IT WAS VERY I
FELT VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT COME FORWARD AND HAVE
ALL OF US VOTE ON THAT, I'M ALSO
PROUD THAT WITHIN THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS, FIVE
OF OUR MEMBERS SERVED BOTH
CAUCUSES AND ADD THEIR VOICES TO
POLICIES THAT PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF WOMEN'S FAMILIES, VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, AND, OF COURSE, OUR
LGBTQ COMMUNITY, WE ALL DESERVE
SOLUTIONS WITH DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIONARY EYES. AND WHEN
THOSE SOLUTIONS COME FORWARD
FROM DIVERSE AND INCLUSIONARY
EYES, THEY TEND TO BE FAR
BETTER. SOLUTIONS TO THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE CONFRONTING.
UNFORTUNATELY, RIGHT NOW, THE
ACLU IS TRACKING NO MORE THAN
515 ANTI LGBTQ PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
515, I HAD THE GREAT FORTUNE ON
SATURDAY TO GO TO AN EVENT WITH
WISCONSIN SENATOR TAMMY BALDWIN,
WHO TALKED ABOUT WHEN SHE PUT
FORWARD THE MARRIAGE EQUALITY
BILL, WHICH PASSED IN THE US
SENATE IN 2022 ON A BIPARTISAN
VOTE OF 61 TO 36. AND SUSAN
COLLINS, SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS,
WHO'S A REPUBLICAN, WAS COAUTHOR
OF THAT. AND SO SENATOR
BALDWIN'S TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE'VE WE'VE MOVED A LOT WHEN YOU
CAN HAVE THESE KIND OF
BIPARTISAN EFFORTS AND SHE WAS,
OF COURSE, QUITE PROUD OF IT.
AND IT DID REMIND ME THAT WE
HAVE MADE GREAT ADVANCES. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WE'VE MADE
THESE GREAT ADVANCES IN
RECOGNIZING THE LEGITIMATE
RIGHTS OF OUR LGBTQ, FAMILIES
AND PEOPLE. WE ALSO SEE THIS
CONCERTED ATTACK. SO THE 515
BILLS I MENTIONED, BUT ALSO THIS
VERY TARGETED AND INCREASED
ATTACK ON ONE SEGMENT OF THAT
POPULATION ARE TRANS POPULATION,
WHICH IS A VERY SMALL PERCENT OF
PEOPLE WITHIN OUR COUNTRY. SO
WHY THEY WOULD DESERVE THIS
UNRELENTING AND VERY FOCUSED
TARGET OF ATTACK IS COMPLETELY
IT'S WRONG AND IT'S UNFAIR. AND
WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO FIGHT BACK ON IT. AND SENATOR
BALDWIN SPOKE TO THAT TOO. AND
SO WE ALSO KNOW IN THE MIDDLE OF
THESE ADVANCEMENTS, BESIDES
THOSE ISSUES THAT OUR LGBTQ
TEENS ARE STILL FAR MORE COMMON
TO BE REJECTED BY THEIR
FAMILIES. AND ALSO HAVE THE
HIGHEST SUICIDE RATE OF ANY OF
OUR TEENS. SO IF WE CARE ABOUT
THESE THINGS, WE CARE ABOUT
BRINGING DOWN SUICIDE RATES AND
BRING IT ABOUT FAMILY
ACCEPTANCE, THEN WE OURSELVES
HAVE TO SHOW ACCEPTANCE TO ALL
OF OUR DIVERSE VIEWPOINTS AND
CREATE THAT MODELING SO THAT
OTHERS FOLLOW IT AND WE, IN FACT
HAVE THE DIVERSITY AND THE
TOLERANCE AND THE ACCEPTANCE
THAT WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR. AND
WITH THAT, I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. SENATOR WIENER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR 96,
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE REMARKS TODAY
, YOU KNOW, I ALSO JUST WANT TO
RISE TO SAY THANK YOU TO SO MANY
OF YOU, OUR ALLIES WHO STAND
WITH OUR COMMUNITY, NOT ONLY ON
THE EASY VOTES BUT ON THE HARD
VOTES. AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE VIEW AS EASY, QUOTE UNQUOTE,
VOTES TODAY, AT LEAST HERE, LIKE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY OR EMPLOYMENT,
PROTECTIONS. AND SO FORTH, DID
NOT USED TO BE EASY. THOSE USED
TO BE VERY HARD. AND THERE WERE
TIMES IN THIS BUILDING WHEN,
WHEN VERY BRAVE MEMBERS CAST
HARD VOTES ON ITEMS LIKE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY AND JEOPARDIZE
THEIR OWN POLITICAL FUTURE BY
DOING SO. AND I'M GRATEFUL TO
THEM, AND NOW WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE, REALLY HARD VOTES AND,
AND, AND SO MANY OF YOU HAVE
STOOD WITH US, WHETHER IT'S
AROUND ALL OF THE MANY WAYS IN
WHICH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THE PRISON SYSTEM
CONTINUE TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
LGBTQ PEOPLE AND PUT, THE LIVES
OF LGBTQ PEOPLE AT RISK, AND
YOU'VE STOOD WITH US REPEATEDLY,
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR THAT, OR
SIMPLY PROTECTING LGBTQ, YOUNG
PEOPLE AND CHILDREN WHO ARE AT
SUCH SEVERE RISK OF BEING
REJECTED BY FAMILY THAT THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE. AND IT'S
STILL THE CASE NOW, RISKING
PUTTING THEM INTO HOMELESSNESS.
LIKE WHEN WE WHEN THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO FORCE Ã
FORCE TEACHERS TO TELL, PARENTS
THAT THE KID IS USING A
DIFFERENT PRONOUN, WHICH COULD
PUT THAT KID'S LIFE AT RISK. ALL
OF THESE ISSUES AROUND LGBTQ
YOUNG PEOPLE AND KIDS, THAT ARE
HARD VOTES BECAUSE, QUÊ ANON HAS
BECOME SO PERVASIVE, IN TERMS OF
DEMONIZING THESE KIDS,
DEMONIZING, ANY EFFORT TO
SUPPORT THEM, AND, AND YOU STAND
WITH US. AND SO WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE, SENATOR CIERTO
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE WITH SOME
DIFFICULTY BECAUSE I WANT TO
EXPLAIN MY REASONING FOR NOT
JOINING MANY OF YOU AND
SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION AS IT
IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. THERE IS
NO DISAGREEMENT IN RESOLVING TO
TREAT PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS
LGBTQ QUÊ WITH THE SAME DIGNITY,
RESPECT AND LOVE AS ANYONE ELSE,
AND I CERTAINLY DO NOT PROMOTE
ANYBODY THAT PROMOTES HATE OR
HARM TO ANYONE AND CONDEMN THOSE
THAT DO. HOWEVER, THIS
RESOLUTION, AS MANY OF OUR OTHER
RESOLUTIONS DO, IT EXTENDS
BEYOND A SIMPLE PROCLAMATION TO
HONOR THE RIGHTS OF LGBT C¯
INDIVIDUALS BY CELEBRATING
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
CELEBRATING FOR A LONG TIME, AND
MANY OF US ARE JUST WE'RE ON
BOARD AND THAT'S PRIDE MONTH.
THIS RESOLUTION INCLUDES HIGHLY
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES SUCH AS THE
PROTECTION OF PARENTAL RIGHTS
AND THE RIGHTS OF FEMALE
ATHLETES THAT REQUIRE CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION AND FURTHER
DISCUSSION. FOR EXAMPLE, I
CANNOT SUPPORT THE NOTION THAT
MALES IDENTIFYING AS FEMALES
SHOULD RECEIVE THE SAME RIGHTS
GRANTED TO FEMALES UNDER TITLE
NINE. THERE IS A CLEAR IMBALANCE
, AS WE RARELY SEE FEMALE TO
MALE TRANS PERSONS COMPETING IN
MEN'S SPORTS, ESPECIALLY FOR
COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS. YET MALE
TO FEMALE TRANS PERSONS ARE
COMPETING IN WOMEN'S SPORTS,
OFTEN LEADING TO UNFAIR
ADVANTAGES AND DENYING WOMEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE ON A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. THIS
UNDERMINES THE VERY PROTECTIONS
THAT TITLE NINE WAS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE. I ALSO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE INTEGRATION
OF OPPOSITE BIOLOGICAL SEXES IN
LOCKER ROOMS AND BATHROOMS,
ESPECIALLY FOR MINORS IN JUNIOR
HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL.
ADDITIONALLY, ATTEMPTS TO
DIMINISH PARENTAL RIGHTS AND
INVOLVEMENT IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
LIVES, PARTICULARLY DECISIONS
REGARDING MINORS IN OUR SCHOOLS
IN THE NAME OF LGBTQ RIGHTS, ARE
DEEPLY TROUBLING. ON SUCH
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES REQUIRE
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC DISCUSSION TO
ENSURE ANY RESULTING LAWS
REFLECT THE PUBLIC'S MAJORITY
VIEWS, NOT JUST THOSE OF
ADVOCACY GROUPS ENACTING LAWS
THAT UNDERMINE PARENTAL RIGHTS
AND LIMIT THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES. WITHOUT
BROAD PUBLIC CONSENSUS IS A
DIRECT AFFRONT ON PARENTS. IT IS
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT PARENTS FEEL
ANGER AND DISTRUST TOWARDS
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, WHO
PRESUME TO KNOW BETTER THAN THEY
DO ABOUT WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. BUT THAT SHOULD NOT
RESULT IN PEOPLE EXPRESSING HATE
AND VIOLENCE. INCORPORATING
THESE CONTENTIOUS ISSUES INTO
THE RESOLUTION ALIGNS IT WITH A
SPECIFIC POLITICAL AGENDA,
MAKING IT MORE THAN JUST A
STATEMENT OF SUPPORT FOR THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. IT POLITICIZES
THE RESOLUTION DETRACTING FROM
ITS INTENT TO CELEBRATE PRIDE
MONTH MEANINGFULLY FOR ALL OF US
IN THE PAST, I HAVE CHOSEN TO
ABSTAIN FROM VOTING WHEN THE
LANGUAGE OF A BILL WAS OVERLY
CONTENTIOUS. HOWEVER, THIS HAS
SOMETIMES LED TO
MISUNDERSTANDINGS ABOUT MY
REASONING AND OTHERS WHO MAY
REASON WITH ME. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT HATE OR DISAPPROVAL OF
INDIVIDUALS LIVING THEIR LIVES
FREELY. IT IS ABOUT BALANCING
CONFLICTING RIGHTS, CONFLICTING
RIGHTS, AND ENSURING THAT NO
GROUP OVERSHADOWS ANOTHER. FOR
THOSE REASONS, TODAY, I CANNOT
SUPPORT YOU WITH THIS
RESOLUTION. I CANNOT JOIN YOU IN
SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE AUTHORS OF
FUTURE RESOLUTIONS TO SIT DOWN
WITH MEMBERS OF THIS BODY,
INCLUDING ME, WHO HAVE CONCERNS
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A RESOLUTION
THAT WE CAN ALL SUPPORT. I WISH
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF OUR LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR FRIENDS, A HAPPY PRIDE
MONTH. MISTER PRO TEM, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE, I RISE
TO BE ABLE TO PROUDLY HONOR SR
96 AND TO BE ABLE TO HONOR ALL
THOSE LGBTQ CHAMPIONS WHO ARE
WITH US TODAY, TO BE ABLE TO
KICK OFF PRIDE MONTH HERE IN THE
GREAT GOLDEN STATE. YOU KNOW, WE
ARE SO INCREDIBLY PROUD TO
WELCOME THESE 16 ICONS TO THE
SENATE AND TO CELEBRATE THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THIS IS BE
HONEST, NOT JUST THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, BUT THE
POSITIVE IMPACT, THE POSITIVE
IMPACT THEY HAVE HAD ON
COUNTLESS LIVES IN EVERY CORNER
OF THIS GREAT STATE. WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM MADAM CHAIR
OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS AND THOSE
MEMBERS IN THE SENATE, IS THAT
THESE TRAILBLAZERS HAVE PROVED
TO THE REST OF THE WORLD THAT NO
MATTER YOUR BACKGROUND, NO
MATTER YOUR SKIN COLOR, WHO YOU
ARE, WHO YOU LOVE, AND HOW YOU
IDENTIFY, CALIFORNIA WILL ALWAYS
HAVE YOUR BACK AND THEIR WORK.
THEIR WORK IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER. YOU KNOW, SADLY, HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
THE CULTURE WARS HAVE BECOME A
SPORT, A SPORT FOR SOME SCORING
POLITICAL POINTS AT THE EXPENSE
OF HARD WORKING PEOPLE, BANS,
RULES, LAWS CREATED ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ARE BLATANTLY ADVANCED
TO STIFLE MARGINALIZED GROUPS OF
AMERICANS, AND MANY TIMES, LGBTQ
RESIDENTS, JUST FOR BEING WHO
THEY ARE NOT. ON OUR WATCH, NOT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, NOT NOW. NOT
EVER. I WANT TO END IT WITH THIS
TODAY IS A DAY OF THANKS AND
CELEBRATION TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE HONOREES. WE
ARE SO HUMBLED BY THE WORK THAT
THEY DO EACH AND EVERY DAY. TO
BE ABLE TO LIFT UP THIS STATE.
WE ALSO NEED TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE COLLEAGUES, THE COLLEAGUES
THAT WE WORK WITH IN THE SENATE
FROM THE LGBTQ CAUCUS WHO ARE
FEARLESSLY STANDING BY THE SIDE
OF DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION. OUR
COLLEAGUES, LED BY THE SENATOR
FROM STOCKTON, FROM SAN DIEGO,
SAN FRANCISCO, SANTA CRUZ AND
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY, AND OUR
ESTEEMED PRO TEM EMERITUS. THEY
ALWAYS STAND UP AND THEY NEVER
BACK DOWN. AND THEY FACE EVERY
ADVERSITY. YOU ARE INSPIRING TO
ALL OF US AND WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SR 96.
THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM. SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR EGGMAN, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SOMETIMES YOU THINK,
WHERE'S THAT DRILL WHEN YOU NEED
IT? I, I THINK I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR KIND WORDS,
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE, TO
APOLOGIZE TO OUR GUESTS. WE HAVE
15 GUESTS IN THE CHAMBERS WITH
US TODAY WHO REPRESENT ALL OF
OUR LETTERS. AND WE ARE WE DON'T
USUALLY INSULT GUESTS WHEN THEY
COME, BUT WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR COMING AND FOR WHAT YOU DO
EVERY DAY. AND I THINK SOMETIMES
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT THE NOISE
SOUNDS LIKE, IS GOOD BECAUSE IT
REMINDS US BECAUSE AS WE'RE HERE
IN PRIDE AND WE'RE HERE WITH JOY
AND LOVE, WE KNOW THAT OUR
JOURNEY IS NOT OVER AND YOU KNOW
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE BY YOUR
SIDE ON THIS JOURNEY, THAT WE GO
FORWARD TOGETHER. WHEN WE TRY TO
DIVIDE OURSELVES, IT MAKES
PROGRESS VERY DIFFICULT AND WE
ALL SHOULD ALL BE LOOKING FOR
PROGRESS ALL THE TIME. AND HOW
DO WE USE OUR VOICES FOR GOOD?
HOW DO WE USE OUR VOICES FOR US
COMING TOGETHER AND HOLDING UP
EACH OTHER AS THE HUMAN BEINGS
THAT WE ALL ARE, WE'RE GOING TO
NOW DO OUR PRIDE CEREMONY, AND
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE 15
PEOPLE, DIVERSE PEOPLE FROM
ACROSS THE STATE. AFTER WE CALL
THE ROLL. BUT I WAS GOING TO
SAY, I'M NOT DOING IT NOW. I
UNDERSTAND, BUT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
I'M NOT I DON'T WANT TO GO TOO
DEEP INTO EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE
HAVE A TIME ISSUE. BUT THAT
THESE ARE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
ALL ACROSS THE STATE THAT WE
CHOOSE AS PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERVANTS, WHO ARE EDUCATORS, WHO
ARE HEALTH CARE WORKERS, WHO ARE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZERS, WHO ARE
PRIDE PEOPLE, PEOPLE
REPRESENTING THEIR COMMUNITY
EVERY SINGLE DAY, JUST DOING
THEIR JOB. AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT. AND WE HONOR YOU AND WE
RESPECT YOU. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE. VOTE ON SR 96. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HELEN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. DODD. AYE. Dð RUSSELL.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO
OCHOA. PADILLA PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. SATO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
DALLEY GROVE. HURTADO. JONES
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. BOGH
PADILLA. RUBIO. AYE. SATO WILK.
AYES 29. NO. ZERO RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. MADAM CAUCUS
CHAIR, PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
HONORARY PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
NOW IS THE TIME WHERE WE GET TO
ACTUALLY HONOR, OUR, OUR
HONOREES, SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
DIFFERENT MEMBERS WHO HAVE
NOMINATED PEOPLE DO THE
RESOLUTION, FOR SOME. AND THEN
I'M GOING TO DO SOME OF THE
OTHER ONES. AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO GO UP FRONT AND HAVE A GROUP
PHOTO. BUT AGAIN, THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT WE'VE SELECTED FOR
THIS YEAR THAT REPRESENT FOLKS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND
AGAIN, WE CONTINUE TO INVITE YOU
TO JOIN US TONIGHT. AND IF YOU
DIDN'T SEE THE DIKES ON BIKES
ROARING UP THE CAPITAL MALL, YOU
MISSED SOMETHING TODAY. SENATOR
ATKINS, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY AN HONOR. THIS IS MY 14TH
AND LAST YEAR AS A LEGISLATOR.
AND, TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THREE INCREDIBLY WONDERFUL
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE SAN DIEGO
REGION GIVES ME GREAT PRIDE
TODAY. SO I'M GOING TO START AND
INTRODUCE TO YOU, ARACELI
SHELLEY MUHAMMAD, AS ONE OF OUR
LGBTQ CAUCUS PROUD HONOREES.
SHELLEY'S CAREER SPANS TWO
DECADES IN NONPROFIT SOCIAL
SERVICES AND SEVEN YEARS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. HER LEADERSHIP
PROWESS IS INDISPUTABLE, AND SHE
IS THE BEST EXAMPLE OF VOLUNTEER
DEVELOPMENT AND MANAGEMENT AND
COMMUNAL STEWARDSHIP. AS THE
PARTNERSHIP DEVELOPMENT MANAGER
FOR THE NATIONAL UNIVERSITY'S
PUBLIC SAFETY OUTREACH, SHELLEY
EMBODIES HER ROLE WITH
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY GROWTH. SHE IS AN
APPOINTED COMMISSIONER BY
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS, WHERE SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO SHAPE THE
LANDSCAPE OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. AFTER LEADING THE
MAJOR VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS AS PART
OF SAN DIEGO PRIDE, THOUSANDS OF
VOLUNTEERS HOURS. SHE THEN
CREATED HER OWN THRIVING
NONPROFIT VOLUNTEER WITH
SHELLEY. SHE AND HER TEAM BRINGS
OUT HUNDREDS OF VOLUNTEERS FOR
COMMUNITY EVENTS IN SAN DIEGO
EVERY MONTH. PREVIOUSLY, SHE
SERVED AS DIRECTOR OF VOLUNTEER
SERVICES AND COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT AT THE
SAN DIEGO LGBTQ COMMUNITY CENTER
AND THE CHIEF OPERATIONS OFFICER
FOR THE UNITED STATES POLICE AND
FIRE CHAMPIONSHIPS. SHE FORMERLY
WORKED WITH ME WHEN I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO CITY
COUNCIL. SHE IS MY FRIEND.
SHELLEY TRULY EXEMPLIFIES THE
SPIRIT OF COMMUNITY SERVICE AND
LEADERSHIP. AND I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN HONORING HER TODAY.
DOES SHE.
MADAM PRESIDENT, NEXT I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU ALL
PARISYAN, ANOTHER INCREDIBLE
ADVOCATE BEING RECOGNIZED BY OUR
CAUCUS TODAY FOR HER LEADERSHIP
AND HER ACTIVISM. PARIS IS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BASED DRAG
ENTERTAINER, A BUSINESSWOMAN,
AND AN ADVOCATE FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. SHE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SAN DIEGO AND CREDITS
HER HILLCREST COMMUNITY WITH
PLAYING AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN WHO
SHE IS TODAY. HER PARENTS USE
SAN DIEGO'S LGBTQ CENTER
SERVICES DURING HER COMING OUT,
AS WELL AS THROUGHOUT HER
TRANSITION, WHICH INSPIRED HER
TO FURTHER HER OWN OUTREACH.
NOW, AS AN ADULT AND WITH
OTHERS, SHE'S A VOLUNTEER, A
FUNDRAISER. SHE'S DEVOTED HER
LIFE, HER SKILLS AND RESOURCES
TO THE BETTERMENT OF THE QUEER
COMMUNITY WITH A FOCUS ON OUR
YOUTH AND OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. ALL STAGE.
SHE IS A REGULAR FIXTURE IN
GOVERNMENT SPACES, CORPORATE
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOL CAMPUSES,
TRAINING IN LGBTQ RIGHTS AND
GENDER SENSITIVITY. SHE SHARES
HER JOURNEY AS A TRANS PERSON IN
HOPES OF A GENTLER WORLD FOR OUR
COMMUNITY, AND PUTTING A FACE TO
THE POSSIBILITIES OF WHAT CAN
HAPPEN WHEN OUR COMMUNITY IS
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE.
PARIS'S WORK HAS A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON OUR LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY AND ALL OF SAN DIEGO.
AND I AM A HUGE FAN GIRL. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING HER TODAY.
MADAM PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES,
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING BRUCE
ABRAMS AS ONE OF OUR CAUCUS
HONOREES. BRUCE IS A DEDICATED
ATTORNEY, ACTIVIST,
PHILANTHROPIST, AND PILLAR FOR
OUR LGBTQ PLUS AND OUR JEWISH
COMMUNITIES. THROUGHOUT HIS
SUCCESSFUL LAW CAREER, HE HAS
WORKED WITH MANY UNDER
REPRESENTED CLIENTS BY PROVIDING
PRO BONO LEGAL SERVICES AS HE
SERVES IN VARIOUS LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS, INCLUDING ON THE SAN
DIEGO JEWISH FEDERATION'S ISRAEL
AND OVERSEAS COMMITTEE, THE SAN
DIEGO DIPLOMACY COUNCIL ADVISORY
BOARD, THE SAN DIEGO SHERIFF'S
LGBT ADVISORY BOARD, THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE'S BOARD
EXECUTIVE ALLYSHIP COMMITTEE,
AND IS ONE OF THE CO-CHAIRS OF
THE 16TH ANNUAL SAN DIEGO HARVEY
MILK DIVERSITY BREAKFAST. HE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS CHAIR OF
THE SAN DIEGO CITY'S
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS BOARD,
CHAIR OF OUR SAN DIEGO HUMAN
RELATIONS COMMISSION, AND GRAND
MARSHAL FOR THE PRIDE PARADE IN
2014. HIS SERVICE WITH CIVIL
RIGHTS AND LGBTQ PLUS GROUPS IN
SAN DIEGO HAS MADE AN INCREDIBLE
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY. I HAVE
KNOWN BRUCE AND WORKED WITH HIM
FOR OVER ALMOST 40 YEARS. BRUCE,
I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR OUR SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY AND THRILLED TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR
YOU HERE TODAY.
WE'RE NOW LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR WIENER TO CONTINUE IN
OUR PRESENTATION FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. ARE YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO HONOR SAL
ROSELLI AS A PRIDE MONTH HONOREE
. ONE OF MY GREAT CONSTITUENTS,
SAL, IS THE PRESIDENT NOW
EMERITUS OF THE NATIONAL UNION
OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS. NYU AND
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY LEADER OF A
CALIFORNIA BASED HEALTH CARE
UNION. BUT BEYOND THAT, SAL IS
ONE OF THE MOST RESPECTED LABOR
LEADERS AROUND AND PERIOD FOR
DECADES AND DECADES, FIGHTING
FOR WORKING PEOPLE, A NATIVE OF
ALBANY, NEW YORK, SAL,
VOLUNTEERED WITH DOROTHY DAY'S
CATHOLIC WORKER MOVEMENT BEFORE
MOVING TO SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
1970S, WHERE HE SERVED AS
PRESIDENT OF THE ALICE B TOKLAS
LGBTQ DEMOCRATIC CLUB, A CLUB
THAT I SUBSEQUENTLY CO-CHAIRED,
AND HE ROSE UP THE RANKS TO LEAD
SEIU LOCAL 250, DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE AIDS CRISIS, SAL
VOLUNTEERED IN SAN FRANCISCO
CARING FOR PEOPLE WITH HIV,
WHILE LOCAL 250 CREATED THE
FIRST LITERATURE FOR EDUCATING
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ABOUT THE
VIRUS, IN 2009, AFTER THREE
DECADES LEADING LOCAL 250 AND
UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS WEST,
SAL BECAME THE FOUNDER AND
FOUNDING PRESIDENT OF NYU, A
UNION THAT NOW HAS 19,000
MEMBERS. HE SITS ON THE BOARD OF
COURAGE CALIFORNIA AND HELPS
LEAD HEALTHY CALIFORNIA, NOW THE
STATE'S LARGEST COALITION OF
SINGLE PAYER HEALTH CARE
ADVOCATES. I ALSO WANT TO SAY
I'VE KNOWN SAL FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS. WE ALSO, IN THE
LEGISLATURE, HAVE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH SAL AND NYU ON
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT, ACCESS
AND WHAT HAS ALWAYS REALLY JUST
BEEN SO APPARENT TO ME WITH SAL
AND WITH THE UNION IS THAT, YES,
IT'S ABOUT THE WORKERS AND
ENSURING SUPPORT FOR THE
WORKERS, BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
PATIENTS. AND SAL TAKES THAT
VERY, VERY BROAD VIEW. AND FOR
THAT WE ARE DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING
SAL ROSSELLI.
SENATOR LAIRD WILL CONTINUE WITH
THE NEXT HONOREE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO HONOR THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF MONTEREY, TYLER
WILLIAMSON, TYLER WAS RAISED IN
A MILITARY FAMILY THAT ENDED UP
LANDING IN MONTEREY. HE WAS AN
EARLY GRADUATE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OF
MONTEREY BAY. HE PLANTED HIS
ROOTS THERE. HE BECAME ACTIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY. HE ORGANIZED
PRIDE. HE VOLUNTEERED IN HOUSING
. HE REALLY BECAME AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY. AND AT
I THINK IT WAS THE RIPE YOUNG
AGE OF 32, WAS ELECTED TO A FOUR
YEAR TERM ON THE MONTEREY CITY
COUNCIL, AND HE WAS SO STRONG IN
HIS PERFORMANCE, SERVING ON
REGIONAL BODIES IN HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION, THÀNH AND, AND
WATER THAT HE WAS CHOSEN BY THE
PEOPLE OF MONTEREY IN AMONG A
REALLY STRONG MALE FIELD TO BE
THE MAYOR. AND WHEN HE WAS
ELECTED MAYOR, JUST IN HIS
MID-THIRTIES, HE BECAME THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN MAYOR OF
MONTEREY. HE BECAME THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY MAYOR OF MONTEREY. HE
WORKS AT THE NAVAL POSTGRADUATE
SCHOOL, HIS FAMILY IS NEARBY.
HIS HUSBAND, IVAN, IS A TEACHER
IN SALINAS, AND THEY ARE ACTIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY. AND IF THERE'S
ANYBODY THAT'S UP AND COMING AND
YET WORTHY OF A LONG TRADITION
OF BREAKING THROUGH AND SERVING
THE COMMUNITY, IT'S MAYOR TYLER
WILLIAMSON OF MONTEREY. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO HELP HONOR HIM TODAY
AS ONE OF OUR PRIDE HONOREES.
SENATOR EGGMAN WOULD DO THE REST
OF THE PRESENTATIONS FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, IT IS MY HONOR.
THIS IS MY, MY HONOREE, LORI
RIZZO IS AN EDUCATOR WITH OVER
33 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH THE
STOCKTON UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
. NOT AN EASY GIG, AND A STATE
COMMISSIONER FOR CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. FIRST
FIVE. FIRST ONE FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO REPRESENT US ON A
STATEWIDE COMMISSION FOR THE
FIRST FIVE, LORI HAS DECIDED TO
DEDICATE HER PROFESSIONAL CAREER
TO THE CHILDREN OF STOCKTON, HER
HOMETOWN. SHE TAUGHT FIFTH AND
SIXTH GRADES FOR 16 YEARS AND
SERVED AS A PRINCIPAL FOR
ANOTHER 16 BEFORE MOVING TO THE
DISTRICT OFFICE TO BECOME THE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES, OVERSEEING 17
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS IN STOCKTON.
UNIFIED IN 2002, LORI ACCEPTED A
NOMINATION FROM SENATOR PRO TEM
ATKINS OFFICE TO SERVE AS A
STATE COMMISSIONER FOR FIRST
FIVE AND A ROLE THAT SHE
CONTINUES TO DO AND IS VERY
PROUD. AND SHE IS HERE WITH HER
WIFE TODAY, KATHY, AND WE'RE
VERY PROUD IN STOCKTON. OF HER.
OKAY. AND NEXT. NEXT. WE HAVE
ACCEPTING ON BEHALF OF SONNY
WOLF, WE HAVE KATE BROWN OF
DIKES ON BIKES. SHE'S ACCEPTING
A, SONNY DIKE WAS BORN IN
GERMANY. BECAME A US CITIZEN AS
A YOUNG CHILD, GREW UP IN RHODE
ISLAND. SONNY WAS DEEPLY
PATRIOTIC AND SERVED STATESIDE
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR, WAS A
MEDIC IN THE UNITED STATES AIR
FORCE. SONNY MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE LATE 1970S. IT
WAS IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT SHE
BECAME. SHE FOUND WHAT BECAME
HER CALLING TO HELP CREATE,
DEFINE, AND DEFEND THE UNIQUE
SPACE WITHIN THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. SONNY WAS THE
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO DIKES ON BIKES, AND
WAS A HEART OF THE CLUB FROM
1978 UNTIL HER PASSING IN 2018.
OVER THE COURSE OF 40 YEARS THAT
SHE WAS WITH DIKES ON BIKES, SHE
HELPED THE ORGANIZATION EVOLVE
INTO A 500 AND 1C3 PROFIT
NONPROFIT AND HELPED SPEARHEAD
THE GROUP'S MISSION TO CREATE A
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY OF WOMEN
MOTORCYCLISTS, SUPPORTING
PHILANTHROPIC ENDEAVORS IN THE
LGBT COMMUNITY. SONNY ALSO
SERVED ON THE BOARD FOR SAN
FRANCISCO PRIDE, WHERE SHE
HELPED CREATE A COMMUNITY THAT
CELEBRATES LGBTQ VISIBILITY AND
EQUALITY. WITH FOUR DECADES OF
ACTIVISM IN THE COMMUNITY, SHE
WAS AN INSPIRING PART OF THE
MOVEMENT FOR THE LESBIAN AND
DIGNITY, WHO WAS SUCCEEDED BY
THE THOUSANDS OF DIKES ON BIKES
AROUND THE WORLD WHO FOLLOW IN
HER FOOTSTEPS. AND WITH US TODAY
WE HAVE KATE BROWN, THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO DIKES
ON BIKES.
OKAY. AND NEXT WE HAVE A FORMER
MAYOR OF CALEXICO. RAUL IS THE
DAUGHTER OF CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE CALEXICO.
SHE WAS THE FIRST TRANSGENDER
LATINA MAYOR OF A CALIFORNIA
CITY AND ON ENTIRELY OF THE AND
ITS ENTIRETY ON THE US AND
MEXICO BORDER. PLEASE
CONGRATULATE HER.
AND NEXT UP, WE HAVE DAVID
DURAN, VICE PRESIDENT OF
RIVERSIDE LGBTQ PRIDE. DAVID IS
A DEDICATED ADVOCATE FOR THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY, CURRENTLY
SERVING AS THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND FUNDRAISING DIRECTOR OF
RIVERSIDE PRIDE TO ADVANCE
INCLUSIVITY AND DIVERSITY IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. RIVERSIDE PRIDE
SPEARHEADS INITIATIVES THAT
UPLIFT AND EMPOWER OUR COMMUNITY
INDIVIDUALS, ENSURING THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD AND THEIR NEEDS
ARE MET. CONGRATULATIONS.
OKAY. NEXT UP WE HAVE JAI
RODRIGUEZ. ACTOR. ACTOR IS AN
ACTOR AND ARTIST WHO IS KNOWN
FOR HIS ROLE AS THE CULTURE
VULTURE ON QUEER EYE FOR THE
STRAIGHT GUY. HE WAS ALSO KNOWN
FOR HIS BROADWAY ROLES IN RENT
AND ZANNA. DON'T HE CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT IMPORTANT LGBTQ+ CAUSES
AND CAPTIVATES AUDIENCE WITH HIS
ONE MAN CABARET SHOW. PLEASE
WELCOME TO OUR FLOOR.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE JOHNNY COTA.
JOHNNY IS AN AMERICAN FASHION
DESIGNER KNOWN FOR HIS UNIQUE
APPROACH TO AVANT GARDE DESIGN,
BLENDING STREETWEAR AND HIGH
FASHION. HE WAS THE WINNER OF
AMAZON'S PRIME VIDEO FASHION
COMPETITION SERIES MAKING THE
CUT, AND CONTINUES HIS
PROMINENCE IN LOS ANGELES AS A
BOUTIQUE OWNER, CONSULTANT AND
ACTIVIST. PLEASE WELCOME JOHNNY.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE SIR LADY JAVA
ACCEPTED BY HILLARY SAHAR,
ACTIVIST AND ENTERTAINER. LADY
JAVA, A PIONEERING TRANSGENDER
ENTERTAINER AND ACTIVIST, BROKE
BARRIERS IN THE 1960S AND 70S BY
CHALLENGING DISCRIMINATORY LAWS
AND PRACTICES IN LOS ANGELES.
HER COURAGEOUS EFFORTS AGAINST
UNJUST REGULATIONS SIGNIFICANTLY
ADVANCE TRANSGENDER RIGHTS AND
CONTINUES TO INSPIRE THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY TODAY. WELCOME.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE NGUYEN PHAM,
PRESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO PRIDE
IS THE FIRST VIETNAMESE PERSON
TO SERVE AS PRESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S PRIDE, SAN
FRANCISCO'S LARGEST ANNUAL EVENT
AND ONE OF THE LARGEST ANNUAL
GATHERINGS OF LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE
AND ALLIES. PLEASE WELCOME
NGUYEN.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE RON RUIZ,
ENTERTAINER, ENTREPRENEUR AND
PHILANTHROPIST. RON RUIZ IS AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND IS THE BOARD
PRESIDENT OF VIVE, A SUBSTANCE
USE RECOVERY CENTERS, A NEW
NONPROFIT STARTUP FOR
INDIVIDUALS STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND A BOARD MEMBER AT
LATINO EQUALITY ALLIANCE, A
NONPROFIT THAT EMPOWERS OUR LGBT
PLUS QUÊ YOUTH. WELCOME.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE SIERRA FERNANDO
, MANAGER, COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
OFFICE OF LGBTQ AFFAIRS. SARA IS
THE MANAGER AND LEADER FOR THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA'S OFFICE
OF LGBTQ AFFAIRS. SARA BELIEVES
THAT CREATING DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE SPACES WHERE
AUTHENTICITY IS CELEBRATED AND
PROVIDING ACCESS TO COMMUNITIES
ACROSS INTERSECTIONAL
IDENTITIES, EMPOWERS ALL OF US
TO ACHIEVE MORE. WELCOME SARA.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR HONOREES.
THIS YEAR. LET'S GIVE THEM A BIG
HAND. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
GROUP PHOTO WITH ALL THE
HONOREES AND THE LGBTQ CAUCUS
MEMBERS FIRST, THEN I WOULD
INVITE THE REST OF THE SENATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PHOTO. WE'RE
GOING TO. WE'RE GOING TO COME TO
THE FRONT HERE. WE'RE GOING TO
COME TO THE FRONTIER.
IF ANY ALLY WISHES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PHOTO, NOW IS
THE WORD NO. NEVER MIND. WE'RE
MOVING ON. NO ROOM FOR ALLIES
TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO OUR
PROGRAM IN ABOUT 15 SECONDS.
SENATORS.
ALL RIGHT, SENATORS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO OUR SENATE.
THIRD READING. WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON SENATE THIRD READING,
13, 14 AND 17. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH SENATOR CABALLERO FOR
ITEM 13. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION SIX BY SENATOR
CABALLERO RELATIVE TO VETERANS
BENEFITS. SENATOR CABALLERO
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT MEMBERS. SAWYER
SIX AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
DENOUNCE THE HISTORIC
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY CREATED UNDER THE
US MILITARY'S DON'T ASK, DON'T
TELL POLICY. SO VÌ CALLS UPON
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT TO CREATE AN
EFFECTIVE REMEDY TO ADDRESS THE
QUOTE, OTHER THAN HONORABLE AND,
QUOTE, DISHONORABLE DISCHARGES
ISSUED UNDER THE DON'T ASK,
DON'T TELL POLICY THAT HAVE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED THE LGBTQ
MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY AND TO
RESTORE THE BENEFITS THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO UNDER THE DON'T ASK,
DON'T TELL POLICY. IF A MEMBER
OF THE MILITARY IDENTIFIED AS A
MEMBER OF THE LGBT Q PLUS
COMMUNITY, IT COULD LEAD TO A
DISHONORABLE DIS, HONORABLE OR
OTHER THAN HONORABLE DISCHARGE.
VETERANS THAT RECEIVED THESE
DISCHARGES LOST ACCESS TO THEIR
MILITARY BENEFITS SUCH AS HEALTH
CARE, COLLEGE TUITION
ASSISTANCE, EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES, AND RETIREMENT
BENEFITS. BETWEEN 1994 AND 2011,
THE DON'T ASK, DON'T TELL POLICY
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
LED TO THE DISCHARGE OF MORE
THAN 14,000 SERVICE MEMBERS.
ADDITIONALLY, PRIOR TO THE DON'T
ASK, DON'T TELL POLICY, THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE ESTABLISHED POLICIES
THAT PENALIZE MILITARY MEMBERS
AND RESULTED IN THE DISCHARGE OF
GAY, LESBIAN, AND BISEXUAL
MEMBERS. REGARDLESS OF SERVICE
TO THE COUNTRY AND THEIR GOOD
MILITARY SERVICE. DURING THE
1980S, MORE THAN 70,000 MILITARY
MEMBERS WERE DISMISSED FROM
THEIR DUTIES DUE TO THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. IN 2010, THE DON'T
ASK, DON'T TELL POLICY WAS
REPEALED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA,
WHICH ALLOWED MEMBERS TO SERVE
OPENLY WITHOUT FEAR OF DISCHARGE
AND CREATED A PROCESS FOR
DISCHARGED MEMBERS TO AMEND
THEIR STATUS THROUGH THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS. THE REVIEW PROCESS TO
GRANT BENEFITS TO A MEMBER WHO
HAS BEEN WRONGFULLY DISCHARGED
IS MADE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
VETERANS REQUIRE AN ADVOCATE TO
GATHER AND SUBMIT DOCUMENTS FOR
THE VA'S REVIEW, INCLUDING
SERVICE RECORDS, INCIDENT
DETAILS, SUPPORTING EVIDENCE AND
PERFORMANCE EVALUATIONS. THE
CURRENT PROCESS TO UPGRADE THE
STATUS OF DISCHARGED VETERANS IS
UNNECESSARILY BURDENSOME, ADDING
COMPLEXITY TO AN ALREADY
STRAINED RELATIONSHIP, FORCING
VETERANS TO REVISIT A DIFFICULT
TIME IN THEIR LIFE CAN CREATE AN
EMOTIONAL BARRIER FOR MANY. IN
MANY CASES, REENGAGING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST THEM WORSENS VETERANS
TRAUMA AND AMPLIFY FEELINGS OF
SHAME, ANXIETY, AND ANGER. SJR
SIX URGES THE PRESIDENT AND
CONGRESS TO ESTABLISH A
STRAIGHTFORWARD PROCESS, PROVIDE
LEGAL AID, AND RECTIFY THE
WRONGFUL DISCHARGE OR
MISCLASSIFICATION OF VETERANS
BASED ON THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. THIS WOULD ENSURE
THEY RECEIVE THE BENEFITS WHICH
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO DUE TO
THEIR HONORABLE SERVICE IN THE
MILITARY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM 13. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO JONES. LAIRD. AYE
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN DALY. GROVE. HURTADO
JONES. WHEN. NILO OCHOA. BOGUE.
PADILLA. SATO WILK. AYES. 29.
NO. ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO ITEM 14
SCR 142. SENATOR LIMON IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 142 BY
SENATOR LIMON RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA NONPROFITS. DAY.
SENATOR LIMON, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR TO PROUDLY
PRESENT SCR 142, WHICH DECLARES
WEDNESDAY, JUNE 5TH OF THIS YEAR
AS CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT DAY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO THE
ECONOMY AND WELL-BEING OF THIS
STATE. NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE FOUNDATIONAL
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THEY ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PARTNER WITH
GOVERNMENT AND STRONG ECONOMIC
POWER. THEY RANK AS THE FOURTH
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN THE STATE BY
NUMBER OF JOBS, EMPLOYING OVER
1.2 MILLION PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
MANY SECTORS. THEY GENERATE
APPROXIMATELY 15% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GROSS STATE
PRODUCT, GENERATE NEARLY $274
BILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUE AND
CONTRIBUTE MORE THAN $37 BILLION
IN REVENUE EACH YEAR AT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS.
THIS WEDNESDAY WE WILL HONOR 117
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVEL CHAMPIONS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT, SCIENCE, SAFETY,
NET INNOVATION, CIVIL RIGHTS,
ARTS AND HUMANITIES, AND CIVIC
IDEALS. THEY ENSURE PEOPLE DO
NOT GO HUNGRY, PROVIDE AID
DURING THE PANDEMIC. WATCH OUR
CHILDREN AFTER SCHOOL, HEAL
COMMUNITY DIVIDES AND PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE AFTER
NATURAL DISASTERS. THERE ARE SO
MANY REASONS WHY NOW IS AN
EXCITING YET CHALLENGING TIME TO
BE A NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU SENATOR. SEN.
CABALLERO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
ONE SECOND HERE. OKAY. LET'S TRY
AGAIN. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO SUPPORT MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA. WE COULDN'T SURVIVE AS
A STATE. WE, OUR COMMUNITIES,
COULD NOT SURVIVE WITHOUT
NONPROFITS, HAVING RUN A
NONPROFIT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS,
I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO TRY TO
MEET THE NEEDS THAT COME IN THE
FRONT DOOR AND TO FUNDRAISE
CONSISTENTLY AND LIKE EVERY DAY,
BUT THEY TAKE CARE OF THE
ABSOLUTE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. AND SO I WANT TO I
WANT TO COMMEND MY, MY, MY
FRIEND FROM SANTA BARBARA AND
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT SCR 142 FOR
THE GOOD WORK THEY DO THAT THEY
DO. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CABALLERO. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FINAL
ITEM 14, SENATOR LIMON, YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD AYE. LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE MENJIVAR. AYE.
MIN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH AYE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN HURTADO. JONES MIN. AYE.
PADILLA WILK. AYES 37. NO. ZERO.
THE AYES 35. NO. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING ON
TO OUR FINAL ITEM ON SENATE.
THIRD READING. SENATOR ALVARADO.
HE IS PREPARED AND READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 145 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL, RELATIVE
TO ALICE PIPER DAY. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE AS A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN CAUCUS ALONG
WITH OUR ESTEEMED CAUCUS CHAIR,
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
BERNARDINO TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 145, WHICH
COMMEMORATES ALICE PIPER DAY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WELL, MANY
OF YOU ARE LIKELY HEARING OF
ALICE PIPER FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I FIRST WAS INTRODUCED TO THE
ALICE PIPER LEGACY WHILE ON MY
LISTENING TOUR IN INDIAN COUNTRY
OVER OUR SPRING BREAK. ALICE
PIPER WAS A PAIUTE WOMAN WHO
MARKED HISTORY AND A TRAILBLAZER
IN EDUCATION EQUITY. SHE MADE
HISTORY IN 1924 BY SUCCESSFULLY
SUING THE BIG PINE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF INYO COUNTY TO
INTEGRATE CLASSROOMS AND ALLOW
INDIGENOUS STUDENTS TO ATTEND
THEIR SCHOOLS. SHE WAS ONLY 15
YEARS OLD. BORN ON JUNE SEVENTH,
1908, IN BIG PINE. ALICE
ATTENDED A NEARBY INDIAN DAY
SCHOOL RUN BY THE BUREAU OF
INDIAN AFFAIRS. THIS SCHOOL HAD
OPENED IN 1891 DURING THE HEIGHT
OF THE ASSIMILATIONIST MOVEMENT,
OR MODEL, OF NATIVE AMERICAN UN
EDUCATION. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OPERATED THESE
SCHOOLS TO SEVER NATIVE CHILDREN
TIES WITH THEIR INDIGENOUS
CULTURES. LANGUAGE AND CUSTOMS,
AND HOMELAND, REPLACING THEM
WITH ANGLO AMERICAN CURRICULUM
THAT EMPHASIZED CAREERS IN
MANUAL LABOR. THESE INDIAN DAY
SCHOOLS WERE GROSSLY
UNDERFUNDED, OFFERED VERY FEW
GRADE LEVELS, AND HAD A POOR
QUALITY OF EDUCATION AS COMPARED
TO THOSE OFFERED TO WHITE
STUDENTS. IN THE LATE 19TH
CENTURY, CALIFORNIA COURTS HAD
AFFIRMED THE RIGHTS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO FOLLOW A SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL DOCTRINE NGUYEN.
NEVERTHELESS, THE 1923 ALICE AND
SIX OTHER NATIVE CHILDREN
ATTEMPTED TO ATTEND THE BIG PINE
HIGH SCHOOL, BUT THE SCHOOL
BOARD DENIED THEM ENTRY DUE TO
THEIR RACE. PIPER SUED ON THE
GROUNDS THAT HER 14TH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS HAD BEEN VIOLATED, AND IN
THE SUPREME COURT CASE, PIPER
VERSUS BIG PINE SCHOOL DISTRICT
NOT ONLY WAS THE OUTCOME CHANGED
THE TREATMENT OF NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS, BUT
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN HER FAVOR.
THIS CASE ALSO SET PRECEDENT
THAT WAS LATER CITED BY CHIEF
JUSTICE WARREN IN THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT. IN A LANDMARK
DECISION CASE, BROWN VERSUS THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION, DECLARING
THAT RACIAL SEGREGATION IN
SCHOOLS WAS AND IS INDEED
UNCONSTITU TIONAL. PIPER'S COURT
VICTORY BECAME THE PIVOTAL
PIVOTAL POINT IN TIME ENDING THE
PRACTICE OF SENDING INDIAN
CHILDREN TO SEPARATE SCHOOLS. I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
COMMEMORATING THE CENTENNIAL
ANNIVERSARY OF THE PIPER VERSUS
BIG PINE DECISION AND DECLARED
JUNE 2ND, 2024 AS ALICE PIPER
DAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE I'M SEEING
NONE. I'M HEARING NONE. THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. DO WE HAVE ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 35. NO. ZERO
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. NOW, ONTO
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS. ITEM 61 AND 62. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ THE ITEMS. ASSEMBLY BILL
2974 2232. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE FIRST ITEM.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA BORG AYE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN HURTADO.
JONES AYE. PADILLA. WILK AYES
36. NO. ZERO. CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED. WE'RE GOING TO BE
RETURNING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR LIMON. THANK
YOU. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RETURN SB 639 TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR FURTHER ACTION. THE DESK
WOULD NOTE. MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE, ANNOUNCED SENATOR
WIENER. AYE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I REQUEST THAT AB
1768 FILE ITEM A 50 BE REMOVED
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DEATHS WERE NOTE. SENATOR
NOTHING FURTHER ON THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE ONE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT. SENATOR
ALVARADO. THANK YOU. THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT AT
APPROXIMATELY 345 IN ROOM 2200.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. JUMPING BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS, THIS
IS OUR TIME FOR ADJOURN. IN
MEMORIES, WE HAVE THREE AIMS.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TODAY TO PAY TRIBUTE TO
MATT GAFFNEY, WHO PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL 1ST, 2024, AT THE AGE OF
73. A LONGTIME RESIDENT IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO, MATT GAFFNEY IS
SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER LAURA
AND HER HUSBAND, MATT, THEIR TWO
CHILDREN, JACKSON AND KENNEDY,
AND HIS DEVOTED PARTNER, KAREN
SMILEY. MATT IS ALSO SURVIVED BY
HIS OLDER BROTHER JOSEPH AND
YOUNGER SISTER MARY ELLEN. HIS
FRIENDS SAY THAT HE HAD A BIG
PERSONALITY WITH AN EVEN BIGGER
HEART. THEY ALSO SAY THAT MATT
WAS NOT JUST A RESIDENT OF SAN
JUAN CAPISTRANO, BUT HE WAS ITS
VERY ESSENCE. MATT'S UNWAVERING
DEDICATION TO THE BETTERMENT OF
SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO HAS LEFT AN
UNFORGETTABLE MARK ON OUR
DISTRICT. HIS SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY BEGAN WHEN HE WAS IN
THE BOY SCOUTS, AND THAT SPIRIT
CONTINUED FOR THE REMAINDER OF
HIS LIFE. AFTER SERVING IN THE
US NAVY, MATT RETURNED TO SAN
JUAN CAPISTRANO AND DEDICATED
HIS TIME TO THE COMMUNITY. OVER
THE YEARS, HE SERVED ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION AND THE
TRAFFIC AND TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. HE WAS A MEMBER OF
THE SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO OPEN
SPACE COMMITTEE, WAS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF CAPISTRANO ANIMAL
RESCUE EFFORT. HE WAS A TWO TIME
PAST COMMANDER OF THE LOCAL
AMERICAN LEGION POST, AND A
LIFETIME MEMBER OF VFW POST
3801. HE WAS A LONGTIME MEMBER
OF THE SAN JUAN HISTORICAL
SOCIETY, AND FINALLY HE COACHED
BOYS FOOTBALL AND GIRLS
SOFTBALL. KNOWN AS MISTER SAN
JUAN. MATT LOVED HIS TOWN AND IT
SHOWED WHILE ON THE OPEN SPACE
COMMITTEE. HE HELPED PASS THE
CITY BOND PROPOSITION MEASURE Y,
WHICH PRESERVED OPEN SPACE FOR
SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO RESIDENTS
AND LED TO FOUR PARKS BEING
BUILT WITHIN A YEAR AND A HALF.
MATT ALSO MARCHED IN THE ANNUAL
SWALLOWS DAY PARADE. SINCE ITS
FOUNDING YEARS. HE ONLY MISSED
ONE PARADE IN 1971 BECAUSE HE
WAS ON NAVAL DUTY. THIS YEAR, HE
WAS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN HIS
FINAL SWALLOWS DAY PARADE AT THE
2024 GRAND MARSHAL. ALTHOUGH HE
WAS FIGHTING CANCER, HE WAS
DETERMINED NOT TO MISS IT. IN
2011, THE CITY OF SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO PLACED MATT GAFFNEY
ON ITS WALL OF RECOGNITION,
HONORING HIS SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY. MATT, THROUGH HIS
LIFELONG DEDICATION, HAS HELPED
MAKE THE COMMUNITY A TOP NOTCH
PLACE TO LIVE, WORK, AND VISIT.
HE WILL BE LOVINGLY REMEMBERED
AND SORELY MISSED BY ALL WE ASK
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR. PLEASE BRING MATT'S
NAME FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. AND,
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MIKE.
MICHAEL GALLO, WHO PASSED AWAY
ON APRIL 3RD. MIKE WAS BORN IN
FITCHBURG, MASSACHUSETTS, IN
APRIL OF 1958. HE WAS AN
EXCELLENT ATHLETE AND IN 2013
WAS INDUCTED INTO THE FITCHBURG
HIGH SCHOOL HALL OF FAME FOR HIS
RECORD SETTING TRACK AND FIELD
EXCELLENCE IN 1980, HE GRADUATED
FROM NORWICH UNIVERSITY WITH A
DEGREE IN CIVIL ENGINEERING AND
THEN SERVED AS AN OFFICER IN
U.S. AIR FORCE UNTIL 1984, WHERE
HE WAS STATIONED AT NORTON AIR
FORCE BASE IN SAN BERNARDINO.
AFTER LEAVING THE AIR FORCE, HE
BECAME AN AEROSPACE ENGINEER,
AND IN 1993, C  FOUNDED KELLY
SPACE AND TECHNOLOGY WITH MIKE
KELLY. MIKE WAS A BELOVED MEMBER
OF HIS COMMUNITY AND WAS
RECOGNIZED FOR LEADERSHIP ROLES
IN MANY BUSINESS, EDUCATION,
NONPROFIT, AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. HE ALSO SERVED ON
THE SAN BERNARDINO CITY UNIFIED
BOARD OF EDUCATION FROM 2011 TO
2020, AND SERVED FOR JUST OVER A
YEAR ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. WITH AN EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT, ONE OF MIKE'S TOP
PRIORITIES WAS TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS
TO LEARN THROUGH DIFFERENT
MODALITIES AND APPROACHES. WHEN
HE WASN'T WORKING OR
VOLUNTEERING, MIKE ENJOYED
SPENDING TIME WITH KIM, HIS WIFE
OF 43 YEARS. CHILDREN, KRISTIN
MARK AND THEIR SPOUSES, AND HIS
FIVE GRANDCHILDREN. I WISH
MIKE'S FAMILY AND FRIENDS PEACE
AND COMFORT DURING THIS TIME OF
DEEP SORROW. I WOULD BE HONORED
IF THIS BODY WOULD ADJOURN IN
MICHAEL'S MEMORY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SENECA TO HIS FAMILY.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
HE MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR SKINNER, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I ASK
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF CHRIS EDLEY JR, THE
FORMER DEAN OF UC BERKELEY LAW
SCHOOL, A LEGAL LEGEND AND A
CIVIL RIGHTS EXPERT. HE WAS ALSO
A POLICY ADVISOR ON SIX
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNS AND
PARTNER IN THE WHITE HOUSE WITH
THREE PRESIDENTS, MEANING HE
WORKED IN THE WHITE HOUSE, CHRIS
EDLEY JR DIED MAY 10TH AT
STANFORD HOSPITAL FROM
COMPLICATIONS OF SURGERY. HE WAS
71. HE SPENT HIS CHILDHOOD IN
PHILADELPHIA, WHERE, DUE TO
RACIAL PREJUDICE, HIS FATHER, A
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL GRADUATE,
STRUGGLED TO FIND WORK AT THE
CITY'S LAW FIRMS. EDLEY WENT ON
TO HARVARD LAW, WHERE HE WAS THE
FIRST SECOND GENERATION AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENT TO EARN A LAW
DEGREE, AND WHILE ATTENDING
HARVARD LAW, HE BEGAN WORK ON
CARTER'S 1976 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN. AFTER GRADUATING, HE
JOINED CARTER'S WHITE HOUSE AND
WORKED ON DOMESTIC POLICY ISSUES
LIKE STAMPING OUT HUNGER, CHILD
WELFARE, AND OTHER DISABILITY
ISSUES. AFTER CARTER'S TERM
ENDED, CHRIS EDLEY RETURNED TO
HARVARD LAW, WHERE HE TAUGHT FOR
23 YEARS WITH A NUMBER OF
INTERRUPTIONS, WHICH I'LL
DESCRIBE. HE TOOK LEAVE,
HOWEVER, AFTER CLINTON'S
ELECTION TO BECOME THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET IN
CLINTON'S WHITE HOUSE. NOW WHAT
EDLEY WAS KNOWN FOR IS THAT HE
WAS A STALWART ADVOCATE FOR
RACIAL EQUITY, ESPECIALLY
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. AND IN 1995,
WHEN AFFIRMATIVE ACTION POLICIES
WERE UNDER ATTACK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, CLINTON NAMED EDLEY TO
OVERSEE A REVIEW OF PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. EDLEY DUBBED
THAT REVIEW MENDED IT, DON'T END
IT. HE RESISTED PRESSURE FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TO ENGAGE WITH
CRITICS OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION,
CALLING THEM DANGEROUSLY
DISINGENUOUS BIAS. HE WROTE THAT
THE GOAL OF THOSE SEEKING TO
DISMANTLE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS
TO PROTECT THE CURRENT
DISTRIBUTION OF PRIVILEGE AND
OPPORTUNITY THAT HAS PRODUCED
WHITE MALE ELITES IN VIRTUALLY
EVERY SECTOR. IN 1991, HE JOINED
THREE OTHER BLACK PROFESSORS
FROM TOP TIER LAW SCHOOLS AND
TESTIFIED AGAINST THE NOMINATION
OF CLARENCE THOMAS, ARGUING THAT
JUSTICE THOMAS THEN THEN A
FEDERAL APPEALS COURT JUDGE, WAS
TOO POLITICALLY PARTIZAN TO MAKE
FAIR DECISIONS. EDLEY RETURNED
TO HARVARD IN 1996, WHERE HE AND
GARY ORFIELD CO-FOUNDED THE
CIVIL RIGHTS PROJECT, WHICH HAS
GENERATED DOZENS OF BOOKS,
PAPERS, CONFERENCES, AND IS A
MODEL FOR LAW SCHOOL RESEARCH
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IN
2004, èC BERKELEY NAMED EDLEY
DEAN OF BERKELEY LAW, WHERE HE
BECAME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO LEAD A TOP TIER LAW
SCHOOL IN THE U.S. ERWIN
CHEMERINSKY, WHO IS THE CURRENT
DEAN OF BERKELEY LAW AND WHO
HAPPENED TO BE A CLASSMATE OF
EDLEY'S AT LAW AT HARVARD LAW,
CALLED HIS FRIEND A TRANSFER
FORMATIVE DEAN, A BRILLIANT
INTELLECT, AND A GREAT SENSE OF
HUMOR. HE MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
IN BERKELEY LAW AND IN EVERY
INSTITUTION THAT HE WAS PART OF.
WHILE AT BERKELEY LAW, EDLEY
WORKED CLOSELY AS AN ADVISER TO
OBAMA'S 2008 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AND JOINED THE
TRANSITION TEAM. BUT HE RESISTED
OBAMA'S EFFORTS TO MAKE HIM PART
OF THE WHITE HOUSE. HE SAID,
NOPE, I NEED TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA, WHERE HE FELT IT WAS
THE GROUND ZERO FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY STRUGGLE THAT
DEFINES THE CIVIL RIGHTS AGENDA,
HE DESCRIBED THAT THE CHALLENGES
IN EDUCATION, HEALTH CARE,
IMMIGRATION AND THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA CAPTURE WHAT THE
BATTLE FOR RACIAL AND ETHNIC
JUSTICE IS TODAY. ACROSS THE
NATION. EDLEY STEPPED DOWN AS
DEAN OF BERKELEY LAW IN 2013 TO
DEAL WITH PROSTATE CANCER, BUT
HE RETURNED TO TEACHING IN 2016
AND IN 2021 WAS NAMED INTERIM
DEAN OF UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION. THERE, HE CO-FOUNDED
THE OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE, A
NONPROFIT THAT PROMOTES SOCIAL
EQUITY THROUGH EDUCATION. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE, MARIA
ECHAVESTE. THEY MET WHILE THEY
WERE BOTH WORKING IN THE CLINTON
WHITE HOUSE. HE ALSO SURVIVED BY
THREE CHILDREN, ONE GRANDCHILD
AND A SIBLING. NOW, WHILE EDLEY
WAS ULTIMATELY UNSUCCESSFUL IN
HIS LIFETIME IN STOPPING THE
DISMANTLING OF AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION, HIS WORK, HIS WRITINGS,
THE INSTITUTES HE STARTED, THE
STUDENTS HE MENTORED, AND MUCH
MORE ARE CARRYING ON HIS LEGACY
AND CONTINUING THE FIGHT. MAY HE
REST IN PEACE AND MAY WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. SENATOR STERN,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. CHRIS EDLEY
WAS MY DEAN IN LAW SCHOOL, AND,
WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
INSPIRED ME TO PURSUE SOCIAL
JUSTICE AS A CAREER THROUGH LAW
IN MY LIFE. AND I WOULD JUST THE
ONLY THING I WOULD ADD TO MY, MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY'S
ELOQUENT WORDS IN HIS MEMORY, IS
HUMOR. IN ADDITION TO A LEGACY
OF INCREDIBLE SCHOLARSHIP AND
PROGRESS, TO FIND LEVITY AND TO
HAVE THE WIT TO DO SO IN A
DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENT LIKE A
BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL CLASSROOM,
WHERE EVERYONE'S COMING AT YOU
ALL THE TIME AND I REMEMBER THAT
FIRST DAY HE WE EVERYONE HAD A
LOT OF OPINIONS, AND WE WERE
PUSHING HIM VERY HARD. AND, I
THINK I TAKE FROM HIM TO NOT
JUST TO HAVE THAT BIG MIND, BUT
TO HAVE THE HUMILITY AND THE
GRACE TO FIND HUMOR. AND TO FIND
LEVITY IN THOSE MOMENTS ABOUT
YOURSELF. HE HAD ALL THE REASON
TO BE A MAN OF GREAT, OF GREAT,
YOU KNOW, SELF-IMPORTANCE. AND
YET HE WALKED VERY, VERY HUMBLY
AND CARRIED A HUGE LEGACY IN HIS
WAKE. SO HE WILL BE MISSED, AND
I HOPE HE REST IN POWER. SENATOR
SKINNER, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING THIS STORY WITH US.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
WE MAY PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
MR. PRO TEM, THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, ENJOY AND
CELEBRATE PRIDE MONTH IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES. AND HERE THIS
EVENING WITH THE LGBTQ CAUCUS.
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY, JUNE
SIX, 2024 AT 9 A.M. THE SENATE
IS ADJOURNED. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY, JUNE 6TH AT 9 A.M.
MEMBERS MEMBERS IN ABOUT 30S.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN OUR SPECIAL
SESSION ON ADJOURN AND MEMORIES.
MEMBERS IN 30S.